this is better than bitcoin this is like
[ __ ] well she's doing well you did an
nft wait till you oh and i've got
something special for you howie tell me
about the nft oh my god so after the
hospital scare i was actually already in
discussions with like a digital artist
in creating a line of nft fart jars
and i figured it'd be cool to have my
farts in the metaverse as well as in the
physical universe she knows that her
husband's into all that yes that's
awesome so yeah we created the
fart jars and they're all very adorable
all are very unique and
might be worth a lot of money
one day soon they do vary in rarity some
are more rare than others more valuable
than others what makes one fart jar more
rare than another um so some of them
have like different toppers little
little stoppers at the top
some of them have something inside the
jar some of them have little redeemable
chests on them so you can you know
redeem it for a physical jar have you
sold an nft yet i in the first week of
launch we sold one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars more than 120 000 worth
of the farjar nfts wow
so it's actually it's been very very
successful it's been taken the nft world
by storm everybody's been talking about
it you know it's been met with some
criticism because i think that i win the
storm
yes maybe that's what i'll ask my
husband for he was asking me what i want
for valentine's day i said nothing but
i'll ask for an nft fart jar well i
think that you should have him
get you
a special howie mandelphart card
oh my god
oh my god that's the best thing
[Laughter]
yeah that's for you
i'm going to meet here you're my
favorite guest ever
oh my god you finally have your own nft
you just wash your
you're the best i love you stephanie
you're the best guest i've ever had i
have my own fart jar nft
yeah
oh my god that's amazing yeah jeremy
will put that up it's probably up on the
screen right now but i wanna is it up on
open is it up for some people to
purchase or does he does he get to
purchase his own does i'm gonna transfer
this to you to your crypto wallet okay
and you can list it you can auction it
off anything you'd like to do or you
could just keep it dad forever forever i
want to keep it right now you know what
we should do
like a digital screen here so it's
always playing in the background and it
looks like you it has your glasses and
everything that's the most amazing thing
isn't it there it is right there
it's so cute
oh my god
i love it
you also did it
is that a condom on top to make it look
bald
i don't know what that is
well
how did you know i was circumcised
that what the top of the jar is
what's the top of the jar it's your head
it's just your head oh it's my head
whichever one you want it to be this is
the best you are the best this is going
to go i want to put this up tonight is
this your first nft this is my first mft
ever how he gets an nft and it's a fart
jar jeremy this goes up today
we got to do a story and i'm going to
post this today i'm going to put it up
today tell you
you know something i have a star in the
hollywood walk of fame yeah this is
better this is the hell yeah it is i
swear to you yeah this is better you
know everyone in like the crypto world
they have their avatars be whatever nft
they got this needs to be your avatar
mandel fart jar on twitter and stuff you
need to change your stephanie matto matt
o'matter what do you want me to say
honestly i don't even care
let's do matteo what do you when
somebody says what's your name how do
you say it stephanie maddow stephanie
maddow but then some people like
sometimes say stephanie motto but it
doesn't matter what they say it's what
you say and you know what the thing is
like my name is really howie mendel
but everybody says mandel
mandela
it's different we're totally different
two different people
[Music]